the family of a UK teenager that was
killed in a fatal crash allegedly
involving an American American woman our
meeting the foreign secretary this
afternoon
well Harry Dunn's parents will speak
with Dominic Raab after questions were
raised about whether suspect and
cyclists was eligible for the full
diplomatic immunity that allowed her to
return back to the United States well
let's get more reaction to this breaking
news we don't buy it skies deaf America
it's a dominant way horn and Dominic it
was yesterday that we were talking to
mark Stevens and he said because this
lady wasn't the diplomats wife she was a
spies wife she shouldn't have diplomatic
immunity it would be under another
reason so what more do we know about
whether the government didn't know or
were misled well the Foreign Office
strenuously rejected mark Stevens claims
he's not the only international lawyer
making these claims but they say that
he's incorrect they say that without a
doubt and securest had diplomatic
immunity as the wife of a diplomat in
inverted commas because we understand he
didn't work for the State Department but
the rules are if you are sent here by
the American government the government
presents a list of people it wants to be
regarded as diplomats the Foreign Office
is obliged to accept that so you could
be a military attache you could be an
intelligence officer as is most likely
in this case but you are for all intents
purposes a diplomat you're given
diplomatic immunity and therefore an
circulars had diplomatic immunity the
problem with this is it's a pretty murky
world and the agreement that extends
that to me immunity to people on this
base has not been published so a lot of
this is kind of secret or without public
knowledge so it's hard to verify the
facts but yeah the government's
insisting that she has the right to
diplomatic immunity I think for the
family though obviously it doesn't
change the bottom line which is they
want to have an explanation from this
woman as to what happened to their son
they have not had that and so they had
determined to get that at whatever the
legal status of the way she's managed to
get out of the country and it has to be
said that we would not know about this
case was it were it not for the Dunn
family's determination and their courage
frankly to get the story out and demand
answers and they came to Sky News
and Lisa Dowd our correspondence hard
work and getting this story worked out
and then getting it on air and only
after that happens did the government
the Foreign Office down histories and
the police say yes we don't think
anything we think something is wrong
here
Boris Johnson came out said diplomatic
immunity had not been applied in the
right way in this process but for two or
three weeks they remained silent it's
only because of Lisa - journalism and
the family's determination so we can
hear now Lisa who's been following this
story all the way through talking to the
Dunn family about what they hope to get
out of this meeting with the foreign
secretary Dominic Raab which we can now
break as news is going to happen at some
point today we've been offered the
chance to now meet with Dominic Raab
we've got that meeting this afternoon
and so we're heading to then look to
London shortly we're very much hoping
for some positivity yes good news
hopefully hopefully is going to tell us
the news we want to hear yeah what do
you want to hear that they've got the
waiver for the immunity and that she's
going to be coming back for justice for
Harry I hope you can look at us as human
beings that just need our UK government
on our side and if we get that
positivity and we get that breakthrough
that we need we can actually start
looking after ourselves and our other
boy who's twin and the extended family
siblings and until we get that
positivity and hopefully the answers we
need we are still in that mode of just
keeping going with that fire in our
belly that still keeps telling us
something is not right so they're
they're very brave family I mean they've
they've they've lost a son
they went obviously they are going
through that grieving process but
compounding that was this complete
Battlement and I'm awesome presumably
thought the world was going mad because
they were found out this woman who they
believe was involved in the accident
just left the country and then the
authorities seem to have very little
more to say about it and
and they have been determined to to get
to the bottom of what has happened to
their son Harry so far what they've
heard from the Prime Minister Boris
Johnson has said he didn't doesn't think
it's right that the process of
diplomatic immunity was used for this
type of purpose the Foreign Secretary
has spoken to his American counterpart
Mike Pompeo the Secretary of State and
also spoke to the American ambassador
here in London yesterday where the
Foreign Office says that he urged
America to reconsider its position and
do the right thing by Harry Dunn's
family so from the British official side
of things there's an acceptance that
diplomatic immunity was not applied in
the right way here certainly in the
words of the Prime Minister and
something needs to be done about it from
the Americans we've really had silence
the the Ambassador is declining all
offers for an interview